yo let me love you
you say uh
we just had a uh
artist named kyle on the show recently
you know super duper kyle yeah that song
i spy yeah yeah so he uh
he was talking about how he has a song
called i spy which is about to be
diamond right he's like damn it wow he's
like that's a i think he's eight times
platinum he's like uh this song has
changed my life
financially it's got me in a place where
like you know yeah it's so it's so big
that i could kind of do what i want now
that's that's the gift and the curse
it's but but it's also like he's also
the i spy guy now you're not you're not
the let me love you guy but let me love
you is one of those songs that is so
massive
between the remix the original it is one
of the most iconic r b songs of all
[ __ ] time yeah what is the curse part
of that for you because we know what the
gift is i think the the curse part of it
is easy it's just
you know
having that level of success again with
another record because i was so young
when it happened
and it's like i haven't had another
record that big even though i've had
other hits right
since that record you know and i think
that's the curse but i think every
artist has well not every artist some
artists got
18 20 number ones right but that's you
know if you're so lucky to have that and
have that type of system man god bless
you that's amazing you know but i think
that's the curse man just like
um
trying to trying to beat it out you know
what i'm saying trying to
argue with another like like obviously
every time i mean that's that's that's a
[ __ ] that's your biggest record are
you tired of performing it after all
these years
i feel like sometimes i'm gonna get
tired of performing it and then when i
perform it it feels like the first time
every time oh it's fire but it's because
of the fans man it's because of the
people it's because of them it's it's
like when you're on stage and you see
like
it's a connection bro because you just
records they they they're like
they're like
time in the flesh bro like this this is
like i feel like recorded sound is time
of the flesh you literally
trap sound time into a sound and you're
able to relive it over and over and over
and over again so in some cases yes it
could feel
as if
you're not moving forward
but
when you see a record transcends so many
generations
and you see
like
i see tick tocks of like babies or like
toddlers singing let me love you i'm
just like bro today yeah of course
such a blessing man